Okay, we're really, really late. We got to start the show. I want to get right into it, but I really want to tell you something about myself that not a lot of people know. But I know you're waiting. I know you're waiting. We should probably get to the show. It's like, it's going to start like any second now, and I can't wait to see what the guest is. I don't know if it's mine or there, it's I don't know if it's because I'm shooting it. I'm looking in the mirror right now, you guys. And I look amazing. I look incredible. I'm wearing a baseball hat. I'm wearing glass. I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
好吧，我们真的、真的很迟了。我们得开始节目了。我想直接切入正题，但我真的很想告诉你们一些关于我自己、没多少人知道的事。但我知道你们在等着。我知道你们在等着。我们可能该开始节目了。这感觉就像，节目随时都会开始，我迫不及待地想看看嘉宾是谁。我不知道是我的还是他们的，我不知道是不是因为我在拍摄。我现在正在照镜子，伙计们。我看起来棒极了。我看起来不可思议。我戴着一顶棒球帽。我戴着眼镜。对不起，对不起，对不起，对不起。
Okay, we'll get right to it. Get right to it. Get right to it. Get right to it. Welcome to Smarlis. Smarlis. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
好吧，我们马上切入正题。马上切入正题。马上切入正题。马上切入正题。欢迎来到 Smarlis。Smarlis。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
We'll mention that he was going to try a couple of new characters today. Oh, yeah, he did. Just a little bit. That he talked about some new characters. Is that what he was saying? Make sure they are an, yeah, yeah. That he talked about some new characters, that what he was saying. Make sure they are an offensive accents, please. Okay. Oh, this guy's a vending.
我们会提到他今天打算尝试几个新角色。哦，对，他确实尝试了。就一点点。他谈到了一些新角色。他是这么说的吗？确保它们是一个，对，对。他谈到了一些新角色，他是这么说的。请确保它们带有冒犯性的口音。好吧。哦，这家伙是个贩卖机。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's sort of stereotypical, what? You don't know anything about that guy's story. You don't know anything about that guy's story. Talk about him. Talk about him. Oh, I, sorry, he. Sorry, sorry.
哦，对，对，对，对。这有点陈词滥调，什么？你对那个家伙的故事一无所知。你对那个家伙的故事一无所知。聊聊他。聊聊他。哦，我，抱歉，他。抱歉，抱歉。
So, and I love talking about my work as an actor and how I got there. And, well, this is a great segue because let me tell you what I want to, I agree. It is what I want to talk about too. I know. Listen, Will and I are fresh off the boat from New York. Oh, yes. We, we do travel by water. We don't like to fly. No, Sean, you'll be quiet. Sean, you will be quiet. You'll be quiet. And, And we're back from New York and we went and saw Sean's play. We had the ballast go. Sorry, the ballast go. We have the honor of seeing Sean in Good Night Oscar at the ballast go. And let me tell you about garbage. You can smell it from a mile away, but when you actually see it. Yeah, trash.
所以，我喜欢谈论我作为演员的工作以及我是如何走到这一步的。嗯，这是一个很好的过渡，因为让我告诉你我想，我同意。这也是我想谈的。我知道。听着，威尔和我刚从纽约乘船来到这里。哦，是的。我们，我们确实走水路旅行。我们不喜欢坐飞机。不，肖恩，你会安静的。肖恩，你会安静的。你会安静的。而且，我们从纽约回来了，我们去看了肖恩的戏剧。我们去了... 抱歉，是去……。我们有幸在……观看了肖恩主演的《晚安，奥斯卡》。让我跟你讲讲垃圾的事。你在几英里外就能闻到它的味道，但当你亲眼看到它时。对，垃圾。
When you look at trash, it'll pile up. It does. And he does. The flies give it away. Yeah, the flies. I used to date that all the time. Sean, guys, Sean is such a mega town. If you're anywhere near, if you're anywhere near, New York City listener, do your eyes and ears a favor and your heart, quite frankly, and your tear ducts and your laugh machine. And go see Good Night Oscar. Sean, I will and I said it immediately after the standing ovation. No, Sean turned around.
当你看着垃圾时，它会堆积起来。确实如此。他也是。苍蝇暴露了它。对，苍蝇。我以前经常约会那种……。肖恩，伙计们，肖恩太有魅力了。如果你在任何地方，如果你在任何地方，纽约市的听众，为了你的眼睛和耳朵，老实说，为了你的心、你的泪腺以及你的笑声机器，做件好事吧。去看看《晚安·奥斯卡》。肖恩，我会在起立鼓掌后立刻说出来。不，肖恩转过身去。
Sean, Jason was sitting directly in front of me and he turned around and Jason looks at me and he says, Sean's ruined the podcast. He's ruined the podcast. We can no longer, well, who are we going to make fun of now? Who can we just forget? Oh, get ready. I have. And he said, and he said, how is Sean?
肖恩，杰森就坐在我正前方，他转过身来，杰森看着我，他说，肖恩把播客毁了。他把播客毁了。我们再也不能，好吧，我们现在该拿谁开玩笑了？我们还能把谁忘掉？哦，准备好吧。我有。他说，他说，肖恩怎么样？
He goes and does this every night. And I said, not every night. Yeah, not every night. No, they couldn't make that deal. No, but honestly, in all seriousness, a most people on Broadway, they take a day, one night of, no, no, no. I know Sean was talented. I think we all know Sean is talented. Honestly, in all seriousness. In my days and twos, they most people on Broadway, they take, they, one that I've not known. I know Sean was talented.
他每天都这么做。我说，也不是每天。对，也不是每天。不，他们可做不成这笔交易。不，但说实话，严肃地说，百老汇的大多数人，他们会休息一天，休息一晚，不，不，不。我知道肖恩很有才华。我想我们都知道肖恩很有才华。老实说，严肃地说。在我那些日子里，百老汇的大多数人，他们会拿，他们会，我不知道的那个。我知道肖恩很有才华。
I think we all know Sean is talented, but when you see him play this character that takes pure acting skill, and then he plays the piano, I knew he was classically trained, but then to see him play seven minutes of rhapsody and blue, on a company, on a big-ass Steinway in the middle of a Broadway stage and bring the entire audience to their feet with with wet faces from the crescendo of this play with him playing this piano really does play it. I mean, it's just and this character they played, I mean, Sean, I'm really, really, really knocked out. True. Thank you. Absolutely. The most magical night I've ever had in the theater and I know what a weird sentence that is, but, but it's true. Truth. Thank you. Absolutely. The most magical night I've ever had in the theater.
我想我们都知道肖恩很有才华，但当你看到他扮演这个需要纯粹演技的角色，然后他弹钢琴，我知道他是受过古典训练的，但随后看到他在百老汇舞台中央的一架大斯坦威钢琴上弹奏七分钟的《蓝色狂想曲》，并伴奏，让全场观众起立鼓掌，脸上带着这出戏高潮带来的泪水，他弹这架钢琴，真的弹得很棒。我的意思是，这简直……而且他扮演的这个角色，我的意思是，肖恩，我真的、真的、真的很震撼。真的。谢谢。绝对是的。这是我有生以来在剧院经历过最神奇的夜晚，我知道这是一个多么奇怪的句子，但是，但这是真的。真的。谢谢。绝对是的。这是我有生以来在剧院经历过最神奇的夜晚。
And I know what a weird sentence that is, but, but it's true. Well, you've had a few magical nights behind some theaters, but let's find the theaters sitting in the chair, but in the theater. And we, we, that's the theater. That's the theater that's right off Van Aes. Anyway, that's a different story. We'll say that for different podcasts. But Sean, truly, and Jason, you and I were not alone in that.
我知道这是一个多么奇怪的句子，但是，但这是真的。好吧，你在某些剧院后面度过了一些神奇的夜晚，但让我们找找坐在椅子里的剧院，是在剧院里。我们，我们，那就是剧院。那是范尼斯大道旁边的剧院。不管怎样，那是另一个故事了。我们留着以后在别的播客里说吧。但肖恩，真的，还有杰森，你和我并不是唯一有这种感觉的人。
Everybody in that theater felt that it was palpable. It was incredible. We, all of our friends who are there, all of whom are actors and everybody who are like this character that he created, an unbelievable. And what about the Starwaddage that Sean can cram and that not
剧院里的每个人都感受到了，那种感觉触手可及。这太不可思议了。我们，所有到场的我们的朋友，他们都是演员，每个人都觉得这个角色他所塑造的角色，令人难以置信。还有肖恩能塞进去的明星效应，那可不……
just our dumbasses that yeah, it's all our friend is sitting there and he's a part investor in the play. He believes in it so much. And boy, was he feeling smart at the end of it? It's really. It was unbelievable. And in our buddy Frank Marshall was there. He was just beside himself, what also one of the producers of the play. And then just saying, I mean, I mean, everybody was, it was unbelievable. Sean, it was incredible. Marty Short, this is my favorite. So I see Marty and Andrea Martin were sitting in front of you, Jay. And, and so we go to the after party and we're walking over to the table. We're up, we were all sitting and I go by Martin, Martin's at the bar, and there are probably 40 people between him and me. And he looks at me, catches my eye,
不仅仅是我们这些笨蛋，对，我们所有的朋友都坐在那里，他还是这出戏剧的联合投资人。他非常相信它。天哪，事情结束时他觉得自己多聪明啊！真的。这简直难以置信。我们的好朋友弗兰克·马歇尔也在那儿。他简直欣喜若狂，他也是该剧的制作人之一。然后就说，我的意思是，我的意思是，每个人都，这太不可思议了。肖恩，这太棒了。马蒂·肖特，这是我最喜欢的。我看到马蒂和安德烈·马丁坐在你前面，杰、杰。然后，我们去参加会后派对，正朝桌子走去。我们都坐着，我走过马丁身边，马丁在酒吧，我和他之间大概有40个人。他看着我，跟我对视，
and across everybody he shouts, why don't you have talent like that? Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha came up to me at the party afterwards. And the first thing Will Arnett says to me, he goes, hey, I had to get up during the panel part. How did it go? LAUGHTER Oh, we got it. And then you wake up to a nomination from the autocratic circle. I know.
越过所有人，他大喊：“你怎么没有那样的才华？”哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈 - 演出结束后，他来到我派对上。威尔·阿奈特对我说第一句话是：“嘿，我在座谈会上得离开一会儿。进展怎么样？”笑声 哦，我们做到了。然后你醒来就接到了来自自动循环系统的提名。我知道。
You guys are so nice. I really love you. We love you. I love you, guys. It meant, now, let me just say something. It meant the world that you got. It meant the world that you guys, it meant the world that you guys took the time and effort to come out to see me and support me.
你们太好了。我真的很爱你们。我们爱你们。我爱你们，伙计们。这意味着，现在，让我说件事。这意味着，你们花时间和精力出来看我、支持我，这对我意义重大。
I love you guys, you're my brothers. We always talk about it, but I just, you just made my night. So, we'll see you again. I would have done it every night of the week if we had to. That's all the time we have, I think. Okay, go show a wee little listener.
我爱你们，你们是我的兄弟。我们经常谈论这个，但真的，你们让我度过了完美的一夜。所以，我们还会再见面的。如果必须的话，我一周七天每天都会这么做。我想这就是我们所有的全部时间了。好的，去给听众们看个小节目吧。
We have to say, I can't wait. I'm gonna little listener. We have a guest. I can't wait. Wait, I'm gonna take that bye back. Okay. I can't wait. This is so exciting. This is so exciting. Okay. I'm gonna nerd out, guys.
我们不得不说，我等不及了。我要给小听众……我们有一位嘉宾。我等不及了。等等，我要把刚才那句再见收回。好吧。我等不及了。这太令人兴奋了。这太令人兴奋了。好吧。我要化身狂热粉丝了，伙计们。
Okay. So. William Shatton. It's Chubaka. Well, close. It's got Chubaka. Well, close. Our guest today.
好吧。所以。威廉·沙特纳。是丘巴卡。嗯，差不多。有丘巴卡。嗯，差不多。我们今天的嘉宾。
I'm so glad we got him here. I wasn't sure he's available because as they say, he's hot, hot, hot right now in the Hollywood. That's triple high. He really is all anyone talks about right now. At age 11, he was a Texas State swimming champion before throwing in the towel. Don't worry, he still had a speedo on.
我太高兴能把他请到这里了。我不确定他是否有空，因为正如他们所说，他现在在好莱坞是红、红、红得发紫。那是三倍高。现在所有人都在谈论他。在11岁时，他曾是得克萨斯州游泳冠军，后来才放弃游泳。别担心，他当时还穿着泳裤呢。
And heading to the Golden State and then pursuing an acting career. He's become quite the staple in American culture in the last few years, being in the forefront of some major movie and television franchises. The internet refers to him as the ultimate daddy, but probably most importantly,
然后他前往黄金之州，接着追求演艺事业。在过去的几年里，他成为了美国文化中的重要支柱，站在一些主要电影和电视剧特许经营权的最前沿。互联网尊称他为主宰，但可能最重要的是，
he did a reading with me, have a good night Oscar only a few years ago. Oh my God, I was gonna say that. Please welcome my pal, Pedro Pascal. Pedro Pascale. No way. Pedro, hello good morning. Oh, this is a good guy. I'm sliding. Here we go. You can just pull over, turn morning. Oh, this is a good guy.
几年前，他跟我一起在《晚安，奥斯卡》里进行了一次剧本朗读。哦，天哪，我正要这么说。请欢迎我的朋友，佩德罗·帕斯卡。佩德罗·帕斯卡。不会吧。佩德罗，你好，早上好。哦，这是个好家伙。我在滑倒。我们开始吧。你只要把车停靠在路边，转动早上好。哦，这是个好家伙。
I like it. Here we go. You can just pull over, turn your car off and enjoy this. No, no, keep it on, Chris. It keeps going through the speaker's Pedro Pascal. Oh my gosh. No, no, no, no, no. Just on this guy.
我喜欢。我们开始吧。你只要把车停靠路边，熄火，然后享受这个。不，不，克里斯，保持着。声音一直通过扬声器传出来，是佩德罗·帕斯卡。哦，天哪。不，不，不，不，不。就对着这家伙。
Nope, can't do it. Putting the curtain back on. Oh, we had to bail. Oh, no, where'd you go? No, we had to bail. Just kidding. We're all in a Pedro right now. Where am I? I'm in Los Angeles. Oh, you had to be. You had to be. You had to be called. Where are you, Pedro right now? Where am I?
不，做不到。把窗帘拉上。哦，我们得放弃了。哦，不，你上哪儿去了？不，我们得撤了。开玩笑的。我们现在都在佩德罗身边。我在哪儿？我在洛杉矶。哦，你肯定在。你肯定在。你肯定在打电话。你现在在哪儿，佩德罗？我在哪儿？
I'm in Los Angeles. Oh, you are, okay, good. City of Angeles. And in your house, it looks like an empty interrogation room. It's like an, I'm in an empty interrogation room. I'm in Los Angeles. So, what? Can I move a camera around to even,
我在洛杉矶。哦，你在，好吧，很好。天使之城。在你家里，看起来像个空旷的审讯室。就像一个，我在一个空旷的审讯室里。我在洛杉矶。所以，什么？我可以把摄像机转动一下，甚至……
I'm looking at you and I'm sure you're in an empty room. Absolutely, no care. Wow, you're really in an empty room. I've been abducted huh, but they let you do a podcast, but they're but they're fans of your podcast. Oh, wow, that's good Now let me say something. It's true. I'm in the daddies. You've seen Scotty But I'm not hitting you. I'm just celebrating how cool it is that the internet has Collectively referred to you as our daddy and that you embrace it. I've seen you in interviews and stuff like you kind of like that. It's kind of cool. And look, you
我看着你，我确信你在一个空房间里。绝对的，什么都没有。哇，你真的在一个空房间里。我被绑架了吗？但他们让你做播客，但他们是你的播客的粉丝。哦，哇，那挺好。现在让我说点什么。真的。我在爸爸们行列里。你见过斯科蒂。但我不是在打击你。我只是在庆祝互联网集体称呼你为我们的爸爸，而你欣然接受，这有多酷。我看过你的采访之类的，你好像挺喜欢这个。这挺酷的。而且你看，
got the scruff going on. You wear the glasses. I just want people to like me. Well, just keep talking. This is just, you know, the kid. This is what the kids call you. You've got what the kids call Riz. Do we know what Riz is? No, no, what's Riz? Carasma. My kids would say they call it W. Riz. Got that W. Riz is? No, no, what's Riz? Carasma. Okay, this is called... This is called Carasma. My kids would say they call it W-Riz. You got that W-Riz. Wild Carasma. It's a real embarrassment.
你留着胡茬。你戴着眼镜。我只是想让大家喜欢我。好吧，继续说吧。这就是，你知道的，孩子们。这就是孩子们对你的称呼。你拥有孩子们所说的“气场（Riz）”。我们知道什么是“气场”吗？不，不，什么是“气场”？魅力。我的孩子们会说他们称之为W气场。拥有那个W。气场是什么？不，不，什么是气场？魅力。好吧，这叫……这叫魅力。我的孩子们会说他们称之为W气场。你拥有那个W气场。狂野的魅力。真让人尴尬。
I want to talk about Craig Mason. When we get to it. I'm going to have to go to Craig Mason. We're not talking about Craig Mason. The amazing Mason. I want to continue talking about Goodnight Oscar. We have to invite him. You have to invite me.
我想谈谈克雷格·麦辛。等我们聊到那儿。我得去找克雷格·麦辛。我们现在不谈克雷格·麦辛。了不起的麦辛。我想继续聊聊《晚安，奥斯卡》。我们得邀请他。你得邀请我。
No, we have to. Because you got to open him was... Good Lord. Recently? It was... And this is... And the production is directed by Lisa Peterson, right? No, we have, because you got to open was the Lord recently. Yeah, and this is a, and the production is directed by Lisa Peterson, right? Correct. That's correct.
不，我们必须。因为你得开幕是……天哪。最近？那是……而且这是……制作是由丽莎·彼得森执导的，对吧？不，我们必须，因为你得开幕是天哪，最近吗？是的，而且这是一个，而且这部作品是由丽莎·彼得森执导的，对吧？没错。没错。
Incredibly well directed. I did a stage reading for Lisa Peterson 23 years ago at the taper. That's where I met her. It was part of the, I can't remember what the label of the theater festival and festival new works sort of season that it was and I, nothing, I just, I, we're old. Yeah, I point. That makes me move on. At least it's amazing.
导演得非常棒。23年前我在圆锥剧院为丽莎·彼得森做过一次舞台朗读。那就是我认识她的地方。那是，我记不清那个戏剧节和新作品节的演出季叫什么名字了，我，没什么，我只是，我，我们老了。是的，我说得对。这让我继续前进。丽莎太棒了。
Did you like her then? I loved her. It was amazing. I was desperate to get, you know, a job in professional theater, no matter where I was, whether it was Los Angeles or New York. Did that one end up going to stage? It did not.
你那时就喜欢她吗？我太喜欢她了。这太棒了。我渴望得到，你知道的，在专业剧院的工作，无论我在哪里，无论是在洛杉矶还是纽约。那个剧本最终搬上舞台了吗？没有。
If it did, it did not go with me. Did you, so Pedro, did you, you're from Texas, which I did not know? You started, did you start? were you doing theater in Texas? No. No. So I was born in Chile. Yeah, in Santiago, Chile.
如果搬上了，那也不是跟我一起。所以，佩德罗，你是得克萨斯人，我以前不知道？你开始，你开始了吗？你当时在得克萨斯演戏剧吗？没有。没有。所以我出生在智利。是的，在智利圣地亚哥。
Yeah. And I have to say this not brag about the research, Sean. No, no, but I want to say this to you. In La Escuela, seconded secundaria, en la clase de español me llaman va Santiago, porque yo trotigo aléquio Juan. Pero qué bien, Sean. Esto es el diago, perdona. And in the class of Espanyol, may Yamaha Santiago, because I think he's a fan. Perquete, yenshun. It's a Diego perdona.
是的。我不得不说，肖恩，这可不是为了吹嘘你的研究成果。不，不，但我想对你说。在学校，西班牙语课上，他们叫我圣地亚哥，因为……但说得真好，肖恩。这是迭戈，抱歉。在西班牙语课上，他们叫我圣地亚哥，因为我觉得他是粉丝。但是，好样的，肖恩。这是迭戈，抱歉。
Do you notice me Spanish, Sean? Quero de Uyó. I said, see, Boquito. My, I said, in Spanish class in high school, my name was Santiago because it's some other kid picked Juan, which is Sean. Well, this is a great opportunity for you to do what you're doing.
你注意到我的西班牙语了吗，肖恩？我想说。我说，是的，一点点。我的，我说，在高中的西班牙语课上，我的名字叫圣地亚哥，因为另一个小孩选了胡安，也就是肖恩。好吧，这对你来说是一个很好的机会，去展示你正在琢磨的那个角色。
Launch the Spanish character you're working on. Well, I would like to, but my character is from Bolivia, it's Hadley's always not so. It's very close by, but I'm so sorry. That's better than the arbitrary Latino accents I have shared with the guy. By the way, Pedro, I want to, I do want to, Sean, you can go, but I do want, now that we're in South America, we're talking about this. Pedro, I am, I got to know you, not personally, but like a lot of people from watching Narcos, I thought you were so fucking great in Narcos.
好吧，我很乐意，但我的角色来自玻利维亚，那里……非常接近，但我非常抱歉。这比我跟那个家伙分享的那些随意的拉丁美洲口音要好。顺便说一句，佩德罗，我想，我确实想，肖恩，你可以走了，但我确实想，既然我们现在身处南美洲，我们在谈论这个。佩德罗，我，我了解你，不是私下里，而是像很多人一样通过看《毒枭》，我觉得你在《毒枭》里演得他妈的太棒了。
I loved, I loved Narcos, and you were so great in Narcos. I loved, I loved Narcos and you were so great in it and it was like, I'm sure it was one of those things you've been working for years and then everybody's like, hey, look at this guy and you're like, hey man, I've been around for a long time. Right. Was that kind of how that happened? I'm filled with talent for years. It was, Narcos was a really lucky job and I think it came on the co-tails of the big fight of Oberyn Martell and the mountain and Game of Thrones and the people over at Netflix realizing that I wasn't living past that episode. And then spoiler alert.
我喜欢，我喜欢《毒枭》，你在《毒枭》里演得太棒了。我喜欢，我喜欢《毒枭》，你在里面演得太棒了，这就像，我确信这是那种你已经工作多年然后每个人都说，嘿，看这家伙，而你会说，嘿，伙计，我已经混了很久了。对。事情就是那样发生的吗？我多年来一直充满才华。这是，\\《毒枭\\》是一份非常幸运的工作，我认为它是伴随着奥柏林·马泰尔与魔山在《权力的游戏》中的那场大战而来的，Netflix那边的人意识到我活不过那一集。然后，剧透警告。
It's spoiler alert. Sorry, everybody. From 10 years ago. I see I'm not a Game of Thrones fan. So I didn't, I've never watched. It's not that you're not a fan. You just haven't seen it. It was a splashy guest role of the season. Okay. Sort of at the height of the game's popularity. The game. The games. We're good. God. It's early for me. Not only we're not going to cut that. We're going to double that one. Keep going. Well, that was really the first thing that that was the first time I experienced sort of a larger exposure in relation to work in a big way. And that I would say...
这是剧透警告。大家抱歉。来自10年前的剧透。你看，我不是《权力的游戏》粉丝。所以我没有，我从来没看过。不是说你不是粉丝。你只是没看过。那是该季一个轰动的客串角色。好吧。差不多是在该剧热度的巅峰时期。这个游戏。游戏。我们很好。天哪。我起得有点早。我们不仅不会剪掉这个。我们要把这段翻倍。继续。好吧，那确实是我第一次以一种巨大的方式体验到与工作相关的更大曝光度。我会说……
And you met David Benioff in your life, never been the same. Exactly. It completely started there for me as far as consistent work. And so because of Game of Thrones I got Narcos and then That it's it was amazing. We shot the entire thing in Columbia Yeah, it was six to seven months a season and they would have one it was sort of like It was so location-based, you know Which is part of the reason I think the show worked as well as it did because the physical landscape of the show was kind of its secret weapon
你遇到了大卫·贝尼奥夫，你的人生就再也不一样了。没错。就持续的工作而言，它完全是从那里开始的。因为《权力的游戏》，我得到了《毒枭》，然后这太棒了。我们在哥伦比亚拍摄了整部剧。是的，一季要拍六到七个月，而且他们只有一个，这有点像……它是如此依赖外景，你知道的，这也是我认为这部剧之所以成功的部分原因，因为这部剧的实景风貌有点像是它的秘密武器，
in that where we were shooting was kind of the main character of the show more than these larger than life real, dangerous human beings and dangerous circumstances. What was that like working in Columbia? You know, I'm a soft guy. And all I'm thinking about is humidity, and I'm smelling a little bit of mildew on the wardrobe. Um, it went through, we in the jungle
我们在拍摄的地方有点像是这部剧的主角，甚至超过了那些性格张扬、真实、危险的人类和危险的环境。在哥伦比亚工作是什么感觉？你知道，我是一个娇气的人。我满脑子想的都是湿度，而且我闻到服装上有一点点霉味。嗯，我们经历过，我们在丛林里，
and it was tough to get dry. We were sometimes we were in the jungle. The base of production was in Bo-Wil-Tah. And Bo-Wil-Tah is 9,000 feet. Right. And so I'm thinking the crispy snacks at crafty were chewy, right? And so it was tough to get a good crunch out of the chips.
而且很难弄干。我们有时身处丛林。制作基地在波哥大。波哥大海拔9000英尺。没错。所以我在想，剧组餐饮车里的酥脆零食都变韧了吧？所以很难让薯片发出那种酥脆的响声。
You could never. No, no, it was dry. It wasn't humid up in Bo-Boh-Boh-Thai. Like four seasons in a day, and humidity isn't part of it. It gets dry, sunny, rainy, windy, cold. It's generally like Jason's personality, like from Monday to Friday. It's kind of cold, but...
你永远做不到。不，不，那是干燥的。波哥大并不潮湿。一天里有四个季节，湿度并不是其中的一部分。它变得干燥、晴朗、多雨、有风、寒冷。它大体上就像杰森的个性，从周一到周五。有点冷，但是……
Manic. But man cold, but, uh, but, man, but, but, but sometimes, sometimes beautiful. Yeah, hostile, but cool. And the cocaine is always just around the corner. Yeah, exactly. Careful. Jay, I mean, and Jay, what was, and Jay, really, what he wants to know is nice hotel and how close is the private airport.
狂躁。但是人很冷，但是，嗯，但是，但是，但是有时，有时很美丽。是的，充满敌意但很酷。可卡因总是就在拐角处。是的， exactement。小心点。杰，我的意思是，杰，真正，他想知道的是好酒店以及私家机场有多近。
You know, and if he's got that down, then he's happy. I think it's only prop planes going that down, then he's happy. It's only prop planes going in and out of those high outlets. You guys would love Columbia. And not for the reasons you think. It is. Oh, yeah. It's the best.
你知道，如果他搞定了这些，那他就高兴了。我想只有螺旋桨飞机才能在那些高原起降，如果搞定了这些，那他就高兴了。只有螺旋桨飞机在那些高原起降。你们会喜欢哥伦比亚的。而且不是因为你们想的那样。就是这样。哦，是的。这是最好的。
It's the best. I would love it. I would love it. I like the Yellow Socker uniforms. It's all I have to look. You would like the beaches and the mountains and the people. We'll be right back. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp.
这是最好的。我会喜欢的。我会喜欢的。我喜欢黄色的足球队服。我只需要看这些。你会喜欢那里的海滩、山脉和人民的。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由 BetterHelp 赞助。
I don't know if you've noticed, but this is Sean, not Will, and my voice is very low because of doing seven shows on Broadway, and then this podcast, and I love both so much, but my doctor was just like, he's like, you need to take a break from one or the other, and I'm like, well, I can't. And so it stresses me out. I'm still going, I'm still going, I'm still going. But I do need to figure out how to take time for myself, right? And shut up for a second.
我不知道你们有没有注意到，这是肖恩，不是威尔，我的声音很低，因为在百老汇演了七场演出，然后又录这个播客，这两个我都非常喜欢，但我的医生就好像，他觉得你需要从其中一个中休息一下，而我觉得，嗯，我不能。所以这让我压力很大。我还在继续，我还在继续，我还在继续。但我确实需要弄清楚如何为自己腾出时间，对吧？然后闭嘴一会儿。
Which is music to a lot of people's ears. It's easy to get caught up in what everyone else needs from you and never take a moment to think about what you need from yourself. But when we spend all of our time giving, singing, talking, just all of it, it can leave us feeling stretched and burnt out. Therapy can give you the tools to find more balance in your life. So you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind.
这对很多人来说简直是天籁之音。人们很容易陷入满足所有人对你的期望中，却从不花哪怕一秒钟去想想你自己需要什么。但当我们把所有的时间都花在付出、唱歌、说话、把精力全掏空时，这会让我们感到筋疲力尽、精疲力竭。疗愈可以为你提供工具，帮助你在生活中找到更多的平衡。这样你就可以继续支持他人，而不会把自己抛在脑后。
You know, and since Scottie's entire to being my therapist, I actually sought a real one out and they've been helping me tremendously. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire
你知道的，既然斯科蒂承担了当我的治疗师的职责，我实际上自己找了一个真正的治疗师，他们给了我巨大的帮助。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活且适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，
to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help help.com slash smartless. This episode is brought to you in part by carmax. If you have time to watch a cute cat video online, you probably have enough time to get an online offer on your car from carmax. That's right. If you've an online offer on your car from CarMax.
就能与获得执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。通过 BetterHelp 寻找更多的平衡。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com 斜杠 smartless，首月可享 10% 的折扣。那是 better help h-e-l-p 点 c-o-m 斜杠 smartless。本期节目部分内容由 CarMax 赞助支持。如果你有时间在网上看一段可爱的猫咪视频，你大概也有足够的时间在 CarMax 上获得你汽车的在线报价。没错。如果你在 CarMax 上获得了汽车的在线报价。
That's right, if you've been meaning to sell your car, CarMax will make you an online offer in two minutes or less. That's less than a cat video online, isn't it? And you get seven days to think it over, by the way. A CarMax offer is quick, easy, and 100% real. So in the time it takes you to watch internet videos of cats wearing wigs, why not get an offer on your car? Go to carmax.com and get your offer in just two minutes. Then enjoy all the cat content you want. Meow. Car selling reimagined. Car max. Smartlis is brought to you in part by Macy's. Hey guys, Father's Day is just around the corner,
没错，如果你一直想卖掉你的车，CarMax 会在两分钟或更短的时间内为你提供在线报价。这比网上的一段猫咪视频还要短，不是吗？顺便说一句，你有七天的时间来考虑。CarMax 的报价快速、简单且 100% 真实。所以在你观看戴着假发的猫咪的互联网视频所花费的时间里，为什么不去获取你的汽车报价呢？访问 carmax.com，只需两分钟即可获得报价。然后尽情享受你想要的猫咪内容吧。喵。重新构想的汽车销售。CarMax。《SmartLess》部分内容由梅西百货（Macy's）赞助播出。嘿，伙计们，父亲节就要到了，
so you know what that means for me. So find Dad's gift at Macy's. They've got everything from Cologne gift sets to top picks from your Fave influencers. Get some inspiration on the site or zero in on a specific category and use the handy filters to find the perfect gift. You know what, but I'm going to get my father-in-law something. I've already been to the site.
所以你们知道这对我意味着什么。来梅西百货为爸爸挑选礼物吧。他们应有尽有，从古龙水礼盒到你喜爱的网红的精选好评。在网站上寻找灵感，或者锁定某个特定类别，并使用便捷的筛选功能来找到完美的礼物。你知道吗，我要给我岳父买点东西。我已经浏览过网站了。
I have a couple ideas in mind, so I can't wait to discuss with Scottie and Paul the trigger on One Things Specific. So I don't want to say what it is, because it's a surprise, but I'm really excited for my father-in-law. Larry, hi Larry. Plus, you know what? Shop the way you want. Pick up and store, use curbside pickup, or order with same-day delivery to make your
我心里有几个主意，所以我迫不及待地想和斯科蒂和保罗讨论，并对某一件特定的事情下手。所以我不想说是什么，因为这是一个惊喜，但我真的很为我岳父感到兴奋。拉里，嗨，拉里。另外，你知道吗？以你想要的方式购物。到店自提、使用路边取货，或者选择当日达配送，让你的生活更轻松。
life easier. Head on over to Macy's.com. And now, back to the show. I think it's fascinating. I want these guys to hear this because when I was reading about your parents, the political asylum that they had to seek when you were a kid and they're going around the Denmark and then like... By the way, before you get into this, I'm going to ask these guys, Pedro, you know this, but we're going to expose these guys. Do you guys know who the dictator was in Chile, who is, you know, ostensibly just a puppet of the American without
快前往 Macys.com 吧。现在，我们回到节目中。我觉得这太迷人了。我希望这些家伙听到这个，因为当我读到关于你父母的事时，你小时候不得不寻求政治庇护，他们到处去丹麦，然后像……顺便说一句，在你深入这个话题之前，我要问问这些家伙，佩德罗，你知道这个，但我们要揭穿这些家伙。你们知道智利的独裁者是谁吗？他（表面上）只是美国的一个傀儡，不用查资料的话？
looking it up? Paul Dunger. No. Darn is ner. Pinochet. Anyway, keep going. That's all right. Go ahead, Sean. I'm just exposing them, Pedro. No, I mean, if you sit enough vows and consonants that you can kind of manipulate in the edit that he said, Pinochet. I just give it all in your head, Will. Will? But yes. How do you get it all in your head?
保罗·邓格。不对。达恩是纳尔。皮诺切特。不管怎样，继续。没关系。说吧，肖恩。我只是在揭穿他们，佩德罗。不，我的意思是，如果你凑够了足够的元音和辅音，你就可以在剪辑时做点手脚，让他们听起来像是在说，皮诺切特。我只是把它全装在你脑子里了，威尔。威尔？但是，是的。你是怎么把这一切都装进脑子里的？
How's he so smart, Sean? Because I don't think about anything else because my brain, I have very little, I have no street smarts. Pinochet. So your parents fled, so you guys fled is because they were in opposition to Pinochet. Yes. Is that true? Yes.
他怎么这么聪明，肖恩？因为我不会去想别的事情，因为我的大脑，我几乎没什么社会经验。皮诺切特。所以你们的父母逃亡了，你们逃亡是因为他们反对皮诺切特。是的。这是真的吗？是的。
No, it's a lie. Uh-oh. No, but you know, sometimes they build, you sometimes stuff on your Wikipedia gets kind of blown out of proportion. What, what, what was the deal there? Um, then I want to know how much you paid for your name because it's a best name in Hollywood. Well, he's going to get to that because his last name was different.
不，这是个谎言。哦，不。不，但你知道的，有时他们会在维基百科上把事情夸大其词。那，那，那到底是怎么回事？嗯，我想知道你为你的名字付了多少钱，因为这是好莱坞最好的名字。好吧，他马上就要说到这个了，因为他以前的姓氏不同。
Right, he had to change it. Here we go. Yes, I was born Jose Pedro Balmase da Pascal. And my parents, they were just very young when they had my sister and myself, my sister's two and a half years older than me. And there was a cousin of my sister's two and a half years older than me. And there was a cousin of my mother's that was very, very involved in the opposition movement
没错，他不得不改名。我们开始吧。是的，我出生于何塞·佩德罗·巴尔马塞达·帕斯卡尔。我的父母生我和我姐姐时非常年轻，我姐姐比我大两岁半。我母亲有一个表亲，比我大两岁半。我母亲有一个表亲，非常、非常积极地参与了反对
against the military regime. It's proximity to our family. I wouldn't say that my parents were revolutionaries by any stretch of the imagination, but they were very young. And they were young, liberal, college students and ties from my mom's side to close ties to the opposition movement just in terms of family. It was a first cousin of my mother's and my dad was doing his residency at the University Hospital, La Cato-Lica, it's called. And so there was a gun fight that my parents were not involved in.
军事独裁政权的反对派运动。鉴于这种与我们家庭的亲近关系，我不会说我的父母是什么革命者，但他们非常年轻。他们是年轻、思想开放的大学生，而且我母亲这一边的亲戚与反对派运动有着密切的联系，就家族关系而言。那是我母亲的表弟，我父亲当时在大学医院做住院医师，那家医院叫卡托利卡大学医院。所以发生了一场枪战，我的父母并没有卷入其中。
But somebody was wounded, and they brought him to my parents' house so that my father could help tend the wound, hide them for a while. The person that brought them to our house, and I was four months old at the time. He was taken into custody and tortured and gave names and then they came looking for my parents. Wow. And so then my parents had to go into hiding for about six months as it's been told to me, and they, you know,
但有人受伤了，他们把他带到我父母家，好让我的父亲帮忙处理伤口，并把他藏匿一段时间。把那个人带到我们家的人——我当时四个月大——被拘捕并遭到酷刑逼供，说出了名字，然后他们就来找我的父母了。哇。于是我的父母不得不开始大约六个月的逃亡生活，据他们告诉我的，他们，你知道的，
like some sort of political thriller from the early 80s, they found a way to, they saw that these, there was a change of guard at the Venezuelan embassy, where one guy got off the bus, the same bus that the other guy would get on to to switch places. And so there was this window where they could get in there. You know, climb over the wall, like physically
就像80年代初的某种政治惊悚片一样，他们想方设法，发现委内瑞拉大使馆的警卫换岗时有一个空档，一个人下了公车，而另一个人要坐同一辆公车去换班。所以有一个窗口期他们可以进去。你知道的，翻过墙，就像身体上
physically climb over the wall and then land on on the other side of the wall and demand asylum. And it worked. Well, one time, Jason, you told Jason, when you were a kid, one time you went to the guard and you didn't have the right pass at corners and you had to go to the gate for and set. One is that true? And I thought about going over the wall, but I was going to park in the main lot and you had to end up walking over to the stage instead of going through gate one. I heard about it.
身体上翻过墙，然后落在墙的另一边，并要求庇护。成功了。杰森，有一次你告诉杰森，你小时候有一次去找警卫，你在拐角处没有带正确的通行证，你不得不去4号门设置……那是真的吗？我当时想翻墙，但我打算把车停在主停车场，结果你最后得步行走到舞台，而不是通过1号门。我听说过这事。
I jumped on the back of a golf cart. Jason got his first job. It was not as similar in the guard. And then the pass was didn't match. I dropped my head shot. I had to double back from my head shot and then a golf golf cart ran over it. Pedro, I, you know, I remember one of the reasons I know of this stuff. When I was in 1981, and these guys, no, I'm good on dates, the movie Missing came out.
我跳上了一辆高尔夫球车的后面。杰森得到了他的第一份工作。和那个警卫的情况差不多。然后通行证不匹配。我把我的定妆照弄掉了。我不得不折回去找我的定妆照，然后一辆高尔夫球车从上面轧了过去。佩德罗，我，你知道的，我知道这件事的原因之一。1981年的时候，这些家伙，不，我对日期很在行，电影《失踪》上映了。
It was Cissy Spacec, Jack Lemon and John Chayerson and as well, he's the guy who goes missing. And my mom took me to see it in the theater. It was probably too young, my mom. And, but I was probably too young, but, but she took me anyway. And it had such an impact on me to see how other people were living. I was too young, my mom. But I was probably too young, but she took me anyway. And it had such an impact on me to see how other people were living in really in a real way, like a real, so it's always, I've always, I haven't paid attention necessarily, but I always knew that that was the reality in that part of the world, especially at that
主演是西席·斯派塞克、杰克·莱蒙和约翰·谢亚森，还有，他就是那个失踪的人。我妈妈带我去电影院看的。我可能太小了，我妈妈。但是，我可能太小了，但我妈还是带我去了。这对我产生了如此巨大的影响，看到其他人是如何生活的，以一种真实的方式，一种真正的方式，所以我一直，我虽然没有刻意去关注，但我一直都知道那是那个世界那部分地区的现实，特别是在那个
time. And it accrues to me as you're telling this and you're so good at telling this story and you're such a, you do have that risk, you're very charismatic. Has it ever occurred to you, have you ever thought about sort of writing a story based on that or doing no? No.
时候。当你讲述这些时，我突然意识到，你太擅长讲这个故事了，而且你是一个，你确实有那种气场，你非常有魅力。你有没有想过，你有没有想过根据那段经历写一个故事或者做……不？不。
Can we write it and would you do it? It's really fascinating. I mean, it is fascinating, man. It's what an unbelievable story. It's totally unbelievable. I saw missing myself when I was a kid. It is such an imprint in my brain when I saw it. Because of how close I could relate it to my parents' experience.
我们可以写，你会演吗？这真的很迷人。我的意思是，这真的很迷人，伙计。这是一个多么不可思议的故事。这完全不可思议。我小时候也看过《失踪》。它在我的脑海里留下了深深的烙印。因为我能把它和我父母的经历联系得那么近。
In this case, don't direct that. No, it was close to gravas. Ah. And, and, and you know, experience in this story. All of us don't direct that? No, it was close to gravas. And my mom was like little and beautiful, like, sissy-spasic, you know? And I remember, I think about this now in my middle age, that how strange it is to get information in that way through cinema and related to an kind of immediate experience of my parents that they aren't sharing with me, not that it was this big secret or anything like that, but they just, we just didn't talk about it. You've been back there since? Yeah, yeah, yeah. secret or anything like that, but they just, we just didn't talk about it. Really?
在这个案子里，别指挥那个。不，那是科斯塔·加夫拉斯。啊。而且，你知道，对这个故事的经历。我们所有人……别指挥那个？不，那是科斯塔·加夫拉斯。我妈妈当时既娇小又美丽，就像西席·斯派塞克一样，你知道吗？现在到了中年我才回想起来，通过电影这种方式获取信息，并把它与我父母没有跟我分享的某种直接经历联系起来，是多么奇怪的一件事，倒不是说这是一个弥天大谎或者别的什么，而是我们就是不谈论它。你从那以后回去过吗？对，对，对。不是什么秘密，而是我们就是不谈论它。真的吗？
Have you been back there since? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've been back my whole life. They ended up on the list of part and exiles when I was eight years old. Oh, correct. And so at that point, my older sister and I, we had already gotten sent back on our own, you know, the late 70s, early 80s, four-year-olds traveling by themselves, you know, in the custody of like a stewardess. I did that.
你从那以后回过智利吗？对，对，对。我一辈子都在回去。当我八岁的时候，他们最终被列入了黑名单，成为了流亡者。哦，没错。所以当时，我姐姐和我已经被独自送回去了，你知道的，70年代末80年代初，四个岁的小孩自己旅行，你知道的，在空姐的监护下。我干过这事。
And, but when I was eight, it was like a huge family reunion because there were very large families on both sides that were left behind. And ever since then, we'd go back my whole life. My younger siblings, who were born in the states were actually raised in Chile. So the strange circumstance of having been born there, never living there, going there my whole life, it never being home, but it being home and it's just been this ever present. Do you have a place there now that you go back and like I I don't have I don't have a place there But my siblings and my father do yeah, wow, but a couple other movies you mentioned that were kind of a big like shifting gears here Peggy Sue got married and raising Arizona you said we're like huge and then also your your mom wouldn't let you see a certain movie
但当我八岁的时候，那就像是一次巨大的家庭大团聚，因为留在当地双方的家族都非常庞大。从那以后，我一辈子都在回去。我的弟弟妹妹们虽然在美国出生，但实际上是在智利长大的。所以这就造成了一种奇怪的情况：出生在那里，却从未在那里生活过，一辈子都在去那里，它从来都不是家，但它又是家，而且它一直都存在。你现在在那里有自己的住所可以回去吗？我没有，我没有那里的住所，但我兄弟姐妹和我父亲有，哇。不过你提到的另外几部电影，在这里可以说是大洗牌，比如《佩吉·苏要出嫁》和《抚养亚利桑那》，你说它们非常重要，然后还有，你妈妈不让你看某部电影……
I think my dad my mom didn't care my mom didn't give a shit My dad was really against me seeing the breakfast club. Well, really? Yeah. I could see, he took me to go see first blood, the big chill, you know, anything that he was interested in saying frankly, it didn't matter if it was rated R or not. And, um,
我想我爸爸……我妈妈不在乎，我妈妈才不在乎呢。我爸爸非常反对我看《早餐俱乐部》。真的吗？是的。我可以看，他带我去看了《第一滴血》、《大寒》，你知道的，坦白说，任何他感兴趣的事物，不管它是不是限制级（R级），他都不介意。而且，
Sean's in the breakfast club and the lunch club and the snack club and the burger club and the way we're back. All the sequels. But yeah, I wasn't allowed to see the breakfast club because it was because it was what? Santa Bad message. It was like, yeah, it was like kids complaining about their parents. Yeah, I was like, you know, watching that. That's hysterical.
肖恩演了《早餐俱乐部》、《午餐俱乐部》、《小吃俱乐部》、《汉堡俱乐部》以及我们回来时的那些。所有的续集。不过，是的，我不被允许看《早餐俱乐部》，因为它是，因为它是……为什么？不良信息。这就好像，是的，就像孩子们抱怨他们的父母。是的，我就像，你知道的，看着那个。太搞笑了吧。
I have a thousand questions if you would like to hear one. Okay. complaining about their parents. Like, you know, watching that. That's hysterical. I have a thousand questions if you would like to hear one. Okay. By the way, I guarantee you don't have a fucking thousand. Okay. I do. So you, when you went to, so you came to California, your parent, your dad moved to you, your mom and dad both.
如果你想听的话，我有一千个问题。好吧。抱怨他们的父母。就像，你知道的，看着那个。太搞笑了吧。如果你想听的话，我有一千个问题。好吧。顺便说一句，我保证你他妈的根本没有一千个。好吧。我有。所以，你，当你去到，所以你来到加州，你的父母，你爸爸搬去了，你妈妈和爸爸都去了。
We all came to Orange County in 86, 87. And then you went to, and then things happened. You went to New York, University, NYU. I went to, yeah, and then 18, I went to New York, yeah. Yeah, and you were terrible at waiting tables. I was, I really was. I was a bad waiter. And what restaurant, do you remember?
我们在86、87年来到橙县。然后你去了，然后事情就发生了。你去了纽约，纽约大学，NYU。我去了，是的，然后在18岁时，我去了纽约，是的。是的，你端盘子很烂。我确实，我真的是。我是一个糟糕的服务生。是在哪家餐厅，你还记得吗？
I remember. There's so many. Are you guys, oh, this is the 90s. I started so. I lived in New York in the 90s. I worked at, where's the first place? I started it sort of as coffee barista person in places that definitely don't exist anymore.
我记得。有那么多。你们是，哦，那是90年代。我开始得挺早。我90年代住在纽约。我在，第一家店在哪里？我最初是在一些现在肯定已经不存在的地方当咖啡师。
And then I got a job at Flamingo East. Are you remember Flamingo East on second avenue? Yeah. There was a place on 17 second called Verage. I got a job at Time Cafe. No way. Got fired from Fez Bar. Yes.
后来我在“火烈鸟东区”（Flamingo East）找到了一份工作。你们还记得第二大道的“火烈鸟东区”吗？记得。17街第二大道上有一个地方叫 Verage。我在 Time Cafe 找到了一份工作。不会吧。被 Fez 酒吧解雇了。是的。
All of these sound like dancing clubs. And then I moved up to Flamingo East had a party. They had different, they had an upstairs space and they would throw parties up there. And every once in a while, I got to bartend that. And then... I remember Fred, Fred Armiston had his birthday once at Flamingo East, like 20 years ago.
这些听起来都像是舞厅。后来我跳槽去了“火烈鸟东区”办派对。他们有不同的场地，楼上有个空间，他们会在上面办派对。偶尔，我会去那里调酒。然后……我记得弗雷德·阿米森大约20年前在“火烈鸟东区”过过一次生日。
Really? Upstairs, yeah. And then it was almost like a living room, like there was like a little back room and stuff. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it was this beautiful beautiful space and they fired me. What did you do that was so bad in each of these spots? Yeah, because I read that you got fired
真的吗？楼上，对。然后几乎就像是一个客厅，就像里面还有一个小后房间之类的。对，对。对，那是一个非常非常棒的空间，结果他们把我炒了。你到底在每个地方都做了什么那么糟的事？对，因为我看到报道说你被
over 10 times from different places. In some instances, well, one, I wasn't very good. And what about your work was not good? I didn't have the talent to... The talent. I don't know. Yeah, you know, it does. I think it really does.
不同的地方炒了十几次。在某些情况下，好吧，首先，我当时不太好。那你工作中的什么地方不好？我没有那种天赋去……天赋。我不知道。对，你知道，确实有。我觉得真的需要
Take talent to know how to deal with any kind of customer. More so than the customers is to deal with management, to be honest with you. And to kind of service the system of which you are a part of in terms of that environment. And I wasn't smart enough to kind of keep myself safe and perceived as a reliable, I was always on time and stuff like that, but they didn't like me enough to keep me
天赋才知道怎么应付各种各样的顾客。说实话，比起顾客，更难对付的是管理层。还要去维系你作为其中一部分的那个环境系统。而且我当时不够聪明，没能保护好自己，让别人觉得我靠谱——我总是按时上班之类的，但他们还不够喜欢我，以至于
if I needed to cover my shift again because I was gonna go to Buffalo and shoot a Xerox industrial commercial and get stuck there, you know, because the acting, I was like somebody who's got, I had like a major drug problem just covering, you know what I mean? I'm just feeling, they didn't have the,
如果我需要再调一次班——因为我要去布法罗拍一个施乐（Xerox）的工业广告，结果被困在那儿了，你知道的，因为演艺工作，我当时就像是个……我当时就像是有严重的毒瘾，一直在找借口掩饰，你知道我的意思吗？我只是觉得，他们没有……
they put up with it. And then he tried to tell us he was going to do a Xerox. My inconsistency with the showing up of the thing. And by the way, all right. So you're bad at waiting tables. No, it's really innocent. I really was. I was just stupid.
他们忍了我。然后他试图告诉我们他要去拍个施乐广告。我出勤非常不稳定。顺便说一句，好吧。所以你不擅长当服务员。不，真的很无辜。我真的是。我当时就是太蠢了。
You know, you weren't stupid. I don't believe that for a second. But you know, Pedro, you know that Jason's never, because he grew up in showbiz. This is true story. He's never had one of those kinds of jobs. And I think that you kind of wish to have had. You always wanted to. Yeah. I've always fantasized about waiting tables and bartending.
你知道的，你才不蠢。我才不信呢。不过你知道吗，佩德罗，你知道杰森从来没有——因为他在娱乐圈长大。这是真的。他从来没干过那种工作。而且我觉得你其实挺希望能干过的。你一直都想。对。我一直幻想去当服务员和调酒师。
And I always offer you, every time I have a catering gig over here at the house, when I have people over, I was saying Jason, come on over. You know, we'll be on the earth. And then I end up doing it. You know what's scary is that Jason would have been great. He would have been great. I do, I do like the idea of each table is like a separate stage and you're trying to figure out what that audience needs from you so that you get the best possible tip.
而且我每次在这边的家里办餐饮聚会时，我都邀请你，当我请大家来的时候，我说杰森，过来吧。你知道的，我们要脚踏实地。然后结果还是我自己干。你知道最可怕的是什么吗？杰森其实会干得很棒。他会非常棒的。我是说，我真的很喜欢那种把每张桌子都当成独立舞台的想法，你得琢磨那桌客人需要你从你这儿得到什么，好让你拿到最多的小费。
Yeah. Some, some tables want to be left alone. Other tables want a little bit more show. Here's a trip. Here's what we're to trip you out and that your managers want to have liked it because you would have always demanded a heart out. And so you would have been like, I'm gone before dessert.
对。有些，有些桌的客人希望别去打扰他们。别的桌则希望你多表现一点。给你个诀窍。这就是我们要让你惊艳的地方，而且你的经理一定会很喜欢，因为你总是会要求一个硬性结束时间。所以你会觉得：我在上甜品之前就得走人。
My one joke I was used to do as a waiter, I'd come by with the food and I'd put it down and the customer would say, oh, that looks wonderful. And I'd point to my shirt and I'd go, thanks, I just got it. And that's a tip. That's an extra five percent.
我以前当服务员时常用的一个笑话是，我端着食物过去，把它放下，然后顾客会说：“哦，看起来真不错。”我会指着自己的衬衫说：“谢谢，我刚买的。”然后这就成了小费。这能多拿百分之五的小费呢。
This stupid 24 years old killed every time. So listen, so Pedro. So Buffett the Vampire, sorry. This is the thing that Jason was referring to, which I didn't know. You were credited as Pedro Balmasela. See. And what wide Haskell?
这蠢透了的招数在24岁的时候每次都百试百灵。所以听着，所以佩德罗。所以吸血鬼巴菲，抱歉。这就是杰森刚才提到的那件事，我之前不知道。你演职员表上的名字是佩德罗·巴尔马塞达（Pedro Balmaceda）。看。还有怀特·哈斯凯尔（Wide Haskell）？
Oh, literally, it is not your name. I mean, I was just... No, it is. It's at the Dylan. No, no, no, but... Yes, guys, sir. South mean, I was just... No, what is? It's at the Dylan. No, no, but... Yes, guys, sorry. South Americans, we've got a lot of names. Like Jose Pedro, I never went by. My dad is Jose Pedro, and I'm Jose Pedro,
哦，真的，那不是你的名字。我的意思是，我只是……不，是的。就在迪伦（The Dylan）那儿。不，不，不，但是……是的，伙计们，抱歉。南美洲那边，我们有很多名字。比如何塞·佩德罗（Jose Pedro），我从来不用这个。我爸爸叫何塞·佩德罗，我也叫何塞·佩德罗，
and he's, but he grew up as Bepe, and I grew up as Bepe, because Bepe was not a middle name. So Jose Pedro was like a first name, right? And I just grew up as Pedro. And then, and Balmaceda, Pascal is what is on your passport, your birth certificate, Pascal being the maiden name. So Balmaceda is my last name, it's my father's name.
然后他，但他从小叫贝佩（Bepe），我也从小叫贝佩，因为贝佩不是中间名。所以何塞·佩德罗就像是个名，对吧？我从小就叫佩德罗。然后，还有巴尔马塞达·帕斯卡（Balmaceda Pascal）这个名字在你的护照和出生证明上，帕斯卡是我母亲的婚前姓。所以巴尔马塞达是我的姓，是我父亲的姓。
And I went by, so I went by Pedro Balmaceda. And there was a very, very meaningful reason to change it to Pascal, and there was also a very practical reason, and they really meet in the same level of importance, because one, by Maseda, was impossible for people to pronounce. And it just wasn't helping me in terms of auditions and casting. And Pascal is very easy to read and say out loud. And it always felt like a part of my identity. And so when my mother passed away 23 years ago,
我以前用的是，所以我以前用的是佩德罗·巴尔马塞达。把名字改成帕斯卡有一个非常非常重要的原因，也有一个很现实的原因，它们在重要性上其实是不相上下的。因为第一，巴尔马塞达这个姓对人们来说太难发音了。而且它对我的试镜和演员挑选一点帮助都没有。帕斯卡读起来和说出来都很容易。而且它一直让我觉得是我身份的一部分。所以当我的母亲在23年前去世时——
my mother passed away 23 years ago. I made a gradual transition to Pascal. I will say, it is nice and I will say Pedro Bascale is a star named. It's that's so funny because I resisted it for such a long time. It was something that I wanted that I was talked, that I wanted to do, you know, before my mother died. Yeah.
我母亲在23年前去世了。我逐渐过渡改成了帕斯卡。我得说，这很好听，而且我得说佩德罗·帕斯卡是个巨星般的名字。真搞笑，因为我对此抗拒了很长很长一段时间。这是我想要的，是我在母亲去世前就跟人聊过、自己也想做的事。对。
Polarious. But I always thought it was kind of silly because of the pee and the pee. And it sounded like maybe I was trying to create, I don't know what I thought was silly about it. I should have gotten to it much sooner than I did, actually. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor.
太搞笑了。但我一直觉得这有点傻，因为两个P字开头（Pedro Pascal）。听起来好像我是在试图创造……我不知道我当时觉得它傻在哪儿。其实我应该早点改掉的，比我实际行动的时间早得多。对。好了，现在插播一段我们的赞助商广告。
SmartLess is supported by Element. You guys all know I'm doing a show on Broadway right now. Nothing, we all talk about backstage, but how important it is as you're sweating everything out of you on stage to regenerate with electrolytes and not just water, but electrolytes. It's really, really important to keep hydrated so you can do seven-rate shows a week, and that's what it takes. Element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix with everything you need and nothing you don't. That means lots of salt with no sugar.
SmartLess由Element赞助支持。大家伙儿都知道我现在正在百老汇演一出戏。没什么，我们后台经常聊起这个，当你在舞台上挥汗如雨时，用电解质来恢复体力是多么重要，不光是喝水，还要补充电解质。保持水分补充真的非常非常重要，这样你才能一周演七场高强度演出，这就是秘诀所在。Element是一种美味的电解质饮料混合粉，含有你所需的一切，没有你不需要的。这意味着含有大量的盐，却没有糖。
It contains a science-backed electrolyte ratio, 1,000 milligrams of sodium, 200 milligrams of potassium, and 60 milligrams of magnesium. Element is formulated to help anyone with their electrolyte needs and is perfectly suited to folks following a keto, low carb or paleo diet. When you sweat, the primary electrolyte loss is sodium. Acetylates can lose up to seven grams per day. When sodium is not replaced, it's common to experience muscle cramps and fatigue.
它包含经科学证实的电解质比例：1000毫克钠、200毫克钾和60毫克镁。Element旨在满足任何人对电解质的需求，非常适合遵循生酮、低碳或旧石器饮食法的人群。当你流汗时，流失的主要电解质是钠。运动员每天可能会损失高达七克。如果不补充钠，很容易出现肌肉痉挛和疲劳。
They actually just sent me some grapefruit salt, which is my favorite one. I don't usually like grapefruit, but the taste of this one is so delicious. Right now, elements is offering listeners a free sample pack with any purchase. That's eight single serving packets free with any element order. This is a great way to try all eight flavors or share element with a salty friend.
他们实际上刚刚寄给我一些西柚盐味的，这是我最喜欢的口味。我通常不喜欢西柚，但这个的味道太美妙了。现在，Elements为听众提供随任意订单免费赠送试用装的优惠。也就是随任意Element订单免费赠送八个独立包装。这是尝试全部八种口味或与喜欢咸味的朋友分享Element的好方法。
Get yours at drinkelement.com slash smartless. This deals only available through our link. Go to drinklmnt.com slash smartless. Element offers no questions asked refunds. Try it totally risk free. If you don't like it, share it with a salty friend and they'll give you your money back. No questions asked refunds. Try it totally risk-free. If you don't like it, share it with a salty friend, and they'll give you your money back. No questions asked.
登录 drinkelement.com/smartless 获取你的试用装。此优惠仅通过我们的链接提供。访问 drinklmnt.com/smartless。Element提供无条件退款保证。完全无风险尝试。如果你不喜欢，就把它分给一个喜欢咸味的朋友，他们就会把钱退给你。无条件退款保证。完全无风险尝试。如果你不喜欢，就把它分给一个喜欢咸味的朋友，他们就会把钱退给你。没有任何疑问。
You have nothing to lose. SmarterList has brought to you in part by eight sleep. Hey guys, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? Science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep,
你没有任何损失。SmarterList部分内容由8 Sleep赞助。嘿，伙计们，你们知道温度是提高睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗？科学表明，在睡眠的前期和中期，你的体温实际上需要下降，
and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed, based on you and your partner's individual needs.
而在早晨升高，这样你才能快速入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。8 Sleep的智能床罩就像床单一样适合任何床铺。智能床罩会根据你和伴侣的个人需求，自动调节床铺两侧的温度，从而改善你的睡眠。
It can cool down and warm up, and adjusts based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in. It's so great. I have it. It's so easy. Unpack it.
它可以降温和升温，并根据你的睡眠阶段和所处的环境进行调节。太棒了。我有这个。太简单了。拆开包装。
You pull it out. It comes with all these boxes. You set it up. It's super easy. You use the app to walk you through how to do it all. And then you're set. And like for me, you know, Scott and I sleep in separate rooms. So I just like roll on one side of it.
你把它拿出来。里面配了好多的盒子。你把它装好。超级简单。你用应用程序一步步跟着做就行了。然后就搞定了。就像对我来说，你知道的，斯科特和我分房睡。所以我就会滚到它的一侧。
The other like if I'm hot, I roll over to the cold. Or sometimes I sleep right in the middle crease where it's like perfect for my mood hot and cold right in the middle. No, seriously, this thing really works though. It's really incredible. You guys need to try it. While temperature is the biggest game changer,
另一边，如果我热了，我就滚到冷的那一边。或者有时候我直接睡在中间的缝隙里，那里的温度对我来说刚刚好，冷热交替就在正中间。不，说真的，这东西真的管用。太不可思议了。你们得试试。虽然温度是最能改变游戏规则的因素，
the pod cover has other amazing features. For example, thanks to the pod sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights and health certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine, impact your sleep and overall health. Invest in the rest you deserve with the 8th Sleep Pod. Go to 8sleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8 sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8sleep.com slash smartless for
但智能床罩还有其他令人惊叹的功能。例如，多亏了Pod的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都能醒来看到一份为你量身定制的睡眠报告，其中提供了一些见解，告诉你深夜锻炼或咖啡因等某些行为是如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的。投资你应得的优质睡眠，选择8 Sleep Pod。访问 8sleep.com/smartless，购买 8 Sleep 智能床罩即可立省 150 美元。这是你能找到的最优惠价格，但你必须访问 8sleep.com/smartless 才能
$150 off. 8 sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU, and Australia. SmartList is supported by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible offers an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre. You'll find guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities, renowned experts, and exciting
享受 150 美元的优惠。8 Sleep 目前在美国、加拿大、英国、欧盟部分国家和澳大利亚发货。SmartList由Audible支持。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的精选内容或发现全新的好东西。Audible提供涵盖所有类别的海量有声书。你会发现引导式健康计划、戏剧表演、喜剧，以及来自顶级名人、知名专家和音频领域激动人心的新声音的独家Audible原创作品。
new voices in audio. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere, while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. So I've been checking out Atomic Habits by James Clear, I love his last name, it's so apropos. It's a great, great audiobook.
作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中挑选一本永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。Audible应用程序让你随时随地都能轻松聆听，无论是旅行、健身、散步还是做家务，由你决定。所以我最近在看詹姆斯·克利尔（James Clear）写的《原子习惯》（Atomic Habits），我太喜欢他的姓了（Clear），简直太贴切了。这是一本非常非常棒的有声书。
It'll teach you exactly how to form good habits, break bad ones, and master the tiny behaviors that lead to amazing, amazing results. I really, really highly recommend it. You know, and master kind of like the tiny behaviors that lead to amazing, amazing results. I really, really highly recommend it. You know, we always joke about on the podcast how we don't read, but listening to an audiobook seems to be more time efficient for us, and I really, really enjoy actually listening to books.
它会确切地教你如何养成好习惯，戒掉坏习惯，并掌握那些带来惊人成果的微小行为。我真的非常非常推荐它。你知道的，并掌握那些带来惊人成果的微小行为。我真的非常非常推荐它。你知道，我们在播客里总是开玩笑说我们不读书，但听有声书对我们来说似乎更省时，而且我 realmente 非常享受听书的过程。
It's fantastic. I'm reading again with my ears. New members can try Audible free for 30 days days visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. All right back to the show. Now can I ask you can I fan out and dork out about Mandalorian for just a little bit? Go for it. These guys. Hang tight.
太棒了。我又开始用耳朵读书了。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天，访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。网址是 audible.com/smartless，或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500 即可免费体验Audible 30天，audible.com/smartless。好了，回到节目中。现在我能问你吗？我能稍微疯狂地追星、大谈特谈一会儿《曼达洛人》吗？随便问。大家抓紧了。
You're a fucking girl. Jesus. So first of all, I want to know, I've seen every episode. I love it. Me and Scotty, my husband. The laser that you had in your ballot, there's been a lot of discussion. The safety within turn of and then it came from blogboard. Is that true?
你真是个天煞的女孩。天哪。所以首先，我想知道，我看过每一集。我太喜欢了。我和斯科蒂，我丈夫。你在剧里用的那把激光枪，有很多讨论。关于它的安全性能，然后它来自博客板（blogboard）。真的吗？
Was it originally from blogboard? I want Scotty to do a cross in the background in a full-boundalorian. Ask him if they went some blogboard because I'm ready to run. Ready. Scotty, do you have any questions about Mandalorian? Truly asking.
它原本来自博客板吗？我想让斯科蒂在背景里穿上一整套曼达洛人服装走过去。问问他们是不是用了博客板的东西，因为我已经准备好开跑了。准备好了。斯科蒂，你对《曼达洛人》有什么问题吗？真心发问。
Truly, I hope Scotty. I have so many peaks. So the Mandalorian? Truly asking. Truly, I hope Scottie. Scottie. I have so many. So the Mandalorian. So listen, when you have the mask on, can you, I wanna know, can you see, is it really you? Do you do voiceover after what's it like wearing the suit? Do the jets really work?
真心希望斯科蒂。我有好多问题。那么《曼达洛人》？真心发问。真心希望，斯科蒂。斯科蒂。我有太多问题了。那么《曼达洛人》？听着，当你戴着面具时，你能，我想知道，你能看见吗？真的是你吗？你是在事后配音吗？戴着那套制服是什么感觉？喷气背包真的管用吗？
Like what's happening? Like tell me all about it. Oh yeah, it's all real. Yeah, and they're in space too. Yeah. To the mask. Fuck. I'm a huge, and they're in space too. Yeah. Too fast. Fuck. I'm a huge fan.
到底是怎么回事？快跟我讲讲。哦，对，都是真的。对，而且他们也在太空中。对。对着面具。操。我是个超级……而且他们也在太空中。对。太快了。操。我是个超级粉丝。
We're in space. We've always been in space. Sure. And it's really the only way it's similar to Narcos in that regard where it's location-based. Sure. Sure. Sure. And there isn't really any other way to achieve it other than traveling to galaxies
我们在太空中。我们一直都在太空中。当然。在这一点上，这确实是它类似于《毒枭》（Narcos）的唯一方式，都是实景拍摄。当然。当然。当然。除了去到远大星系之外，真的没有别的办法能实现这一点。
far, far away. From our long past, correct? And baby Yoda is real. I can't even have this. Like almost sort of this electric shock that goes through my system if I say that. I don't know why it's totally fine, but Grogu, the child. Right. You're just a Grogu, not baby. It's real, but it's really you under the helmet. So I can't see very well, I can't see very well in the helmet. There was a very extended experimental phase where I was in the suit for so much of it, and establishing what could be established in terms of a physical language, really drawing
从我们遥远的过去，对吧？而且尤达宝宝（Baby Yoda）是真的。我甚至不能……就像有某种电流穿过我的身体如果我说出那个名字。我不知道为什么，这完全没问题，但是格罗古（Grogu），那个孩子。对。你只是个格罗古，不是宝宝。它是真的，但头盔底下真的是你吗？所以我看得不是很清楚，我在头盔里看不太清楚。经历了一个非常漫长的实验阶段，我穿着那套戏服拍了大部分戏，确立了肢体语言方面可以确立的东西，真的借鉴了
so much from guys that were better at it than I was and But how do you do? Do they mic you in the in the helmet? Or do you do voice a mic pack in the there's a mic pack? You're on the show biz, right? On your person, but there's also it's a good question Sean. There's a there's a There's a, there's a, there's a mic pack in the helmet and it's, it's, it's really kind of up against the harder surfaces of your skull. Do they, do they come mic you in your trailer or do you just go over the trolley? Like what the fuck are you doing? And is there a back hole or do you have to take the whole helmet off?
很多比我更擅长此道的人的经验……但是你是怎么做的？他们在头盔里给你装了麦克风吗？还是你……里面有一个麦克风背包？你在娱乐圈混过，对吧？在你身上，但还有一个，这是个好问题，肖恩。里面有一个，有一个，有一个，有一个麦克风背包在头盔里，它，它，它真的有点紧贴着你头骨较硬的表面。他们是在你的化妆车里给你装麦克风，还是你就直接走过去？你到底在搞什么鬼？后面有洞吗，还是你必须把整个头盔摘下来？
Right Sean? Sean, is it true? You told me once that just talking the Mandalorian every time you watch it makes you grow goo. Is that true? I was wrong. I was wrong. I was wrong. You were wrong.
对吧，肖恩？肖恩，是真的吗？你曾经告诉我，每次看《曼达洛人》只要一谈到它就会让你长出格罗古。真的吗？我搞错了。我搞错了。我搞错了。你搞错了。
That's good. I grow a lot of goo when I watch the show. Yeah, for sure. No, that's so interesting. I'm fascinated by the show. I love the show. It's hard to see. It's, you kind of it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it really cool and it takes care of most of the work.
那挺好。我看这节目的时候会长出好多格罗古。对，确实。不，太有趣了。我对这个节目着迷极了。我太喜欢这个节目了。很难看清。你有点……这真的很酷，而且它包办了大部分的工作。
And I have a lot of fun in post because John Favreau gives me a lot of opportunity to kind of edit with him and go over things that they got maybe on the day. And it's really, really surgical, technical work that I've never, yeah, it's like exactly. You don't have a lot of sink issues, right? No, not a lot of lip flap matches.
我在后期制作中玩得很开心，因为乔恩·费儒（John Favreau）给了我很多机会和他一起剪辑，讨论他们可能在现场拍到的东西。这是一种非常非常精细、技术性的工作，我以前……对，就像是完全这样。你不会遇到太多音画不同步的问题吧？对，没有太多口型对不上的情况。
Correct. Yeah, because you can just do it. Now, you know what I'm thinking about in that helmet is, it's just, it's odor, you know, like your own breath, multiple episodes and stuff. So do you have like a lavender wipe that you can go in there? Well, it's more like before you.
没错。对，因为你可以直接演。现在，我在想那个头盔的一点是，它里面一定，有气味，你知道的，比如你自己的呼吸，拍了好几集之类的。所以你在里面会用那种薰衣草湿巾擦一擦吗？好吧，更像是在你……
Yeah. I'm older, of course. Yeah, you put a flower in there or what happens? I was very aware of like my, not only that, but sort of the dark plastic of the tea, you know, because you're like this. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's almost like what your breath smells like,
对。我年纪大了，当然。对，你在里面放朵花还是怎么着？我很清楚我的……不仅如此，还有那种茶色暗塑料，你知道的，因为你就像这样。对，对，对。这几乎就像是你呼出的气味，
like cakes on, like stays there. That's a change in the day. You're not handing that helmet off the second team for lighting, are you? You don't want them in there. Or sound, some dream we might get. They got their own, right? Different helmet, different flower. I'm really surprised.
像蛋糕一样，留在那儿。这是当天的变化。你不会为了打光就把那个头盔转交给B组替身吧？你可不想让他们戴那个。或者为了收音，某些镜头我们可能会换。他们有自己的对吧？不同的头盔，不同的花。我真的很惊讶。
It's so real, Pedro. It's so real. This is giving Giza that would keep him up at night. If he was standing with him. What do you mean we don't have a second team helmet? Like that, that should have just come from the shop Pedro what you need to know is what would happen is the whole thing with the helmet of Jason was doing that He would go to bloom as assistant and then Amanda his wife
太真实了，佩德罗。太真实了。这会让吉扎（Giza）急得夜不能寐。如果他跟他们站在一起的话。什么叫我们没有B组替身的头盔？就像那本该直接从车间拿来一样。佩德罗，你需要知道的是，会发生的情况是，如果杰森遇到头盔这档子事，他就会去找布鲁姆（Bloom）的助理，然后找他妻子阿曼达（Amanda）。
She'd be deep in on the cleaning of that helmet. Jester's no way that Jason can have this He would hand the problem up to eventually his wife and Zach and Alene and everybody. There are these emails. Guys, we got to get Jason's helmet situation sorted out before he shows up on set. Meanwhile, Pedro is a normal nice guy. He shows up. He's like, I'll just roll with it, you know? Yeah.
她会深度参与那个头盔的清洁工作。杰森绝不可能接受这个。他会把问题最终推给他的妻子、扎克（Zach）和艾琳（Aline）以及所有人。有这样的电子邮件。伙计们，我们得在杰森出现在片场之前把他的头盔问题解决好。与此同时，佩德罗是个正常的好人。他出现时态度是：我随遇而安，你知道的？对。
No, you can play at three callbacks from Mandalorian. And I think that was the issue. I think all of the fat bro is this guy's a problem. You couldn't come to an agreement on that. It's understandable. So there are, so there are some on that show, right? Amy Cedaris. No, yes, she is.
不，你为《曼达洛人》进行了三次试镜。我觉得问题出在这儿。我觉得费儒（Favreau）心想这家伙是个麻烦。你们在这个问题上达不成一致。这可以理解。所以，那个节目里确实有一些……比如艾米·塞德丽丝（Amy Sedaris）。不，是的，她确实在。
Yeah, she's the greatest. That was, you know, there was an instant with Amy Cedaris specifically, and that was where she made me laugh so hard that I spat into the helmet. Helmet. Helmet. And that was a moment where I came into a clear understanding of the close proximity that I had to my own, to the things that are in my mouth.
对，她是最棒的。那是……你知道的，具体有一次跟艾米·塞德丽丝合作的经历，当时她把我逗得太厉害了，以至于我把口水吐进了头盔里。头盔。头盔。那一刻，我清晰地意识到了我和自己身体内部、和自己嘴里的东西是多么地贴近。
You're on my saliva. Yes. And it's, you know, or like, launch or breakfast. Here's the best. I love her. Yeah, but listen, I want to talk about your new movie too. It's it's what's it called? Strange way of life. Is that what it is? Strange way of life. Yeah, it's the Ranya Fordima. They beat that. And it's a 30 minute film. That's it. It's just one film. It's a 30 minute short written and directed by Bevdital Almodelar
你沾上了我的唾液。是的。而且，你知道的，或者像午餐或早餐。这是最棒的。我太喜欢她了。对，但是听着，我还想聊聊你的新电影。叫什么来着？《奇异的生活方式》（Strange way of life）。是这个吗？《奇异的生活方式》。对，是佩德罗·阿莫多瓦（Pedro Almodóvar）拍的。这是一部30分钟的电影。就这样。只是一部电影。一部30分钟的短片，由佩德罗·阿莫多瓦编剧并执导，
starring Ethan Hawke. And it's it's gay cowboys who travel across the desert to find each other 25 years apart. Former lovers and one travels across the desert to see him again and and to see him again and it is shot in the same places that Sergio Leoni was shooting his spaghetti westerns in that southern region of Spain. Oh wow, that's cool. On the same sets. That's great. And Sout Laurent does the costumes.
由伊桑·霍克（Ethan Hawke）主演。讲的是两个同性恋牛仔，时隔25年穿越沙漠去寻找彼此。曾经的情人，其中一个人穿越沙漠再次去见他，再次去见他，而且拍摄地点就是塞尔吉奥·莱昂内（Sergio Leone）当年在西班牙南部地区拍摄通心粉西部片的地方。哦，天哪，太酷了。在同一个片场。太棒了。而且服装是圣罗兰（Saint Laurent）设计的。
Wow. And it's me and Ethan. And I'd never worked with Ethan before. I actually listened to him on your podcast. Wasn't he great? He's awesome, isn't he? Yeah, that's so cool. I love him.
哇。主演是我和伊桑。我以前从未和伊桑合作过。我其实在你们的播客里听过他。他不是很棒吗？他太棒了，不是吗？对，太酷了。我太喜欢他了。
It was so great to get to hear you guys get to know him because I spent the summer with him. And I saw movies that he was in, I started with the explorers. Yeah. And then Dead Poets Society and Reality Bites, and then he published a book, and then he was on Broadway,
能听到你们了解他，这真是太棒了，因为我和他一起度过了整个夏天。我看过他演的电影，我从《探索者》（The Explorers）开始看。对。然后是《死亡诗社》（Dead Poets Society）、《现实的创痛》（Reality Bites），然后他出了一本书，然后他在百老汇演戏，
and then he was off-prod-way, and then he directed off-Broadway, and then he was working with friends. And then we were doing this thing with Pedro Motivar, whose movies I saw growing up. I was kind of a family favorite. And it just meant a lot in all earnestness. It was this moment of sort of being listened to and taken seriously by these two influences
然后他演外百老汇，然后他在外百老汇导演话剧，然后他和朋友们一起合作。然后我们又在拍阿莫多瓦的这部作品，阿莫多瓦的电影是我从小看到大的。在我家里算是个最爱。这真的意义重大，说真的。被这两个对我影响深远的人倾听并认真对待，
was a very surreal experience for me because he was my scene partner and this was our director and they wanted to be collaborative and they wanted to, I don't know, all get on the same page at the same level and I felt so influenced by both of them in my upbringing that, you know, this corny is at me, so I don't think these guys care what I think. Yeah. And that was, but
对我来说是一次非常超现实的体验，因为他是我的对手戏演员，这是我们的导演，他们想要合作，他们想要，我不知道，大家处在同一水平线上，达成共识。我在成长过程中深受他们两人的影响，你知道的，不管这听起来多老套，我不认为这两个人在乎我的想法。对。但那是——
you know what, but you know why, Pedro, you know why? And I mean this too, you earn that seat there because you're really good at what you do. Yeah. And I hope you see what we all see, which is an incredible, talent, incredible artist, and you deserve to be there. And that's why that's why you were there in that scene with those guys. Yeah. I know we get to see where we're, where, where do we, where's it going to come out? It's going to premiere a can. Oh, gross. He did a previous short. That was such a nice story. And then you fucking ruined it with your can bullshit. I've never been. Did you get to keep any of the, are you going to go?
你知道吗，但你知道为什么吗，佩德罗，你知道为什么吗？我是认真的，你赢得那个位置是因为你真的很擅长你所做的事。对。我希望你能看到我们大家所看到的，那就是一个令人难以置信的天才、令人难以置信的艺术家，你理应坐在那里。这就是为什么，这就是为什么你会和那些家伙一起出现在那个场景中。对。我知道我们能看到我们在……在哪儿上映？它将在戛纳首映。哦，天哪。他之前拍过一部短片。那是多么美好的一个故事啊。然后你他妈的用你的戛纳废话把它给毁了。我从来没去过。你带走了任何……你要去吗？
I'm going to, I'm going to try to go. I want to go really badly. He did a previous short with Till the Swinton. So this is the second of what could be three installments of these 30 minute English language. Got four aays because everything he's ever done before is in his native language. Hey Pedro, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm techivel, just FYI, I'm just pretty good at it. I'm good at it. Did you get to keep any of the St. Laurent Cowboy stuff?
我打算，我打算试着去。我很想去。他之前和蒂尔达·斯文顿（Tilda Swinton）合作过一部短片。所以这是三部曲中的第二部，这可能是三部全英文的30分钟短片。因为他以前拍的所有作品都是用他的母语。嘿，佩德罗，我，我，我，我，我，我懂技术，顺便说一句，我挺擅长这个的。我很擅长。你有没有留下一件圣罗兰的牛仔服装？
I bet it's some pretty cool stuff now. Then they don't give me nothing. I asked for the green jacket. If you wanna look up the trailer right now, you see me in this kind of like bright green, Jimmy Stewart. Yeah. You know, denim, calcant.
我敢打赌现在有些很酷的东西。他们什么都没给我留。我想要那件绿色的夹克。如果你现在去查预告片，你会看到我穿着那种亮绿色的、吉姆·斯特华（Jimmy Stewart）风格的衣服。对。你知道的，丹宁夹克。
No, they want to hold on to it for possible reshoots? Jacket. No, they just, they just gave me a flat no. Jason wants to know, did it, how was it? Moldy was the jacket moldy? Did you smell it? Did it breathe right out there? Because I imagine
不，他们想留着它以备可能的补拍？夹克。不，他们直接一口拒绝了。杰森想知道，这件衣服怎么样？夹克发霉了吗？你闻过它吗？它在外面透气吗？因为我想象
it was pretty hot. And now it's a little bit of a wick. It didn't have a wicking quality. And the last thing I want you to do, Paige, if only if you want to on SNL, you were so fucking funny on a SNL live. Can you just do a little bit of the voice? One. Can you just do a little bit of the inside of my heart? I don't know what she's talking about. It's so fucking... Stop asking me. I'm not comfortable with Tom. It's really funny. I've been putting in an accent this whole time, and now I finally got to talk with myself.
那一定很热。而且多少有点吸汗。它没有排汗功能。佩德罗，我能请你做的最后一件事是，如果你愿意的话，你在《周六夜现场》（SNL）里真的太他妈好笑了。你能稍微模仿一下那个声音吗？一个。你能稍微学一下我内心深处的声音吗？我不知道她在说什么。太他妈……别再问我了。我对汤姆不自在。真的很好笑。我全程都在装口音，现在我终于可以用自己的声音说话了。
I could listen to that. Well, I found out you guys are like, I'm gonna go. Bye. Pedro, thank you for joining us, my friend. Pedro, we love you. I'm very much. I'm a talent and a friend.
我能听这个听上一整天。好吧，我发现你们俩就像是……我要走了。拜。佩德罗，谢谢你加入我们，我的朋友。佩德罗，我们爱你。非常感谢。你既有才华又是好朋友。
Honestly, you're such a fan, such a huge fan, man. You're so good at what you keep doing. I really love talking to you. By Pedro, we love you. Have a great rest of your day. Thank you. I'm just going to take the headphones off, because I have no idea what that's fine.
说真的，你是个超级粉丝，超级无敌大粉丝，伙计。你做的事情太出色了。我真的很喜欢和你聊天。再见，佩德罗，我们爱你。祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快。谢谢。我要把耳机摘了，因为我完全不知道这有什么好……
Just take them off and walk around. slam the iPad. Yeah. All right. Bye, buddy. Bye, bye, and walk around. slam the iPad. Yeah. All right. Bye, buddy. Bye, bye, bye. Man, he is great. Yeah, yeah.
直接摘下来走开。把iPad摔了。对。好吧，再见，伙计。再见，拜拜，然后走开。把iPad摔了。对。好吧，再见，伙计。拜拜，拜拜。天哪，他太棒了。对，对。
I'm such a massive fan of the last of us. Did you guys watch it? I haven't yet. Did you? Well, did you ever play the game? I did not play the game. No, yeah, it's, it was so good. I saw, I saw the prequel.
我是《最后生还者》（The Last of Us）的超级粉丝。你们看了吗？我还没看。你看了吗？好吧，你玩过那个游戏吗？我没玩过游戏。不，对，这太棒了。我看过，我看过前传。
Oh, here. The first of us. Did you not see? He was. It's so good. I saw the prequel. Oh, here. The first of us. Did you not see? He was. It's so dumb. Of course, it's dumb. What is it? This is a great clean day.
哦，这儿。第一生还者。你没看吗？他是。太蠢了。当然，这很蠢。这是什么？这是一个很棒的干净日子。
What are you talking about? You said, you're doing jokes. Do you need headset to play that game? Is that one of those where you got a? You can. Will's headset. Don't what do you mean? Will's millions of people enjoy themselves.
你在说什么呢？你说，你在开玩笑。你玩那个游戏需要戴耳机吗？那是那种你需要……的吗？你可以。威尔的耳机。什么意思？千百万人玩得很开心。
Wait, what? What is that? But isn't it amazing that like he he started out? So like he's been doing this forever. So when Game of Thrones hit themselves. Wait, he's such a town that guy. But isn't it amazing that like he started out so like he's been doing this forever. So when Game of Thrones hit him, when he was just like Wonder Woman, like all these big things that he's done, he kind of came out of what seemingly always
等等，什么？那是什么？但难道不惊人吗，他一开始……所以他做这个已经很久了。所以当《权力的游戏》火起来的时候。等等，那家伙真是个天才。但难道不惊人吗，他一开始就……所以他做这个已经很久了。所以当《权力的游戏》找到他时，当他刚拍完《神奇女侠》时，所有这些他做过的大项目，他似乎突然从……
the same story all the time, that it seemingly came out of nowhere, but he's been doing this forever. That's what I've been doing. That's my first, yeah. Yeah, so that's why he's like down to earth and normal because he's like, you guys are making all the hype. I'm not making all the hype.
总是同一个故事，似乎凭空出现，但他其实一直都在做这个。这就是我一直在做的事。那是我的第一部，对。对，所以这就是为什么他那么脚踏实地又正常，因为他会想：你们在疯狂炒作。我可没在炒作。
I'm just working, you know? Yeah. I saw him in an interview, one of the, they had him strapped to a lie detector and he's just like so comfortable. An interview, I guess it was more like an interview. Anyway, whatever it was, he was at a police station and he was a strapped truck. No, but he was doing it. And he was just like, and I was marveling at how comfortable he is in his own skin
我只是在工作，你知道吗？对。我在一个采访里看到过他，他们把他绑在测谎仪上，他表现得超级放松。一个采访，我想这更像是一个采访。不管怎样，总之，他在一个警察局里，被绑在卡车上。不，但他在接受测试。而且他就那样……我当时惊叹于他对自己是多么地自如，
and how relaxed and normal he is. And that's why I asked that question. It's like, you can tell he's the guy who's paid his dues and he's been doing it for a long time. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he's not like, oh my God, this is so crazy. Jason, you got to run where you heading to and are you going to, where you going right now?
他是多么的放松和正常。这就是我问那个问题的原因。就像，你能看出他是一个付出了努力、干这一行很久的人。对，对，对。他不会觉得：哦天哪，这太疯狂了。杰森，你得赶快走了，你要去哪儿？你现在要去哪儿？
I get you some charity thing. Are you saving some kids? Yeah, I got to go feed, feed a bunch of folks. Are you going to, are you going to drive? Or are you going to ride your... No, he's going to drive and then he's going to probably... I suck. Oh, he was by...
我要去参加什么慈善活动。你要去拯救一些孩子吗？对，我要去喂饱一群人。你是要开车去吗？还是你要骑着你的……不，他要开车去，然后他可能会……我真逊。哦，他说的是拜拜……
I was going to say bye. Bye. I love you, Sean. How a great show tonight, you strad. I love you, Sean. Have a great show tonight. You're straight. I love you too. Smartness. Smartness.
我要说再见。再见。我爱你，肖恩。今晚演出顺利，你这个直男。我爱你，肖恩。今晚演出顺利。你个异性恋。我也爱你。Smartless。Smartless。
Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。
Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armstrong, and Bennett Barberco. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts, or the Wondri app. on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆斯特朗（Rob Armstrong）和班尼特·巴尔伯科（Bennett Barbakow）100%有机纯手工制作的。Smartless。我们的下一集将在满一周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus或Wondery应用程序来提前收听无广告版。在Amazon Music上，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus或Wondery应用程序来提前收听无广告版。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。